foreign
[Music]
we should go
let's go back
[Music]
leave him
all right
yeah
that story in the weather but first job
[Music]
wasn't even going yet
[Applause]
[Music]
shut up
man stop yelling at me
[Music]
medic
oh Jesus
Beth we should go
millions of dollars worth of cocaine
fell from the sky this morning in
Knoxville Tennessee there's more this
out there they dumped it somewhere I'm
looking for my daughter's first is a
dangerous place hey Henry check it out
something got into it a deer Maybe
a lot of cocaine was lost I need you to
go and get it
no don't eat that don't eat that let's
see what kind of effect that has
[Music]
cocaine
there was a bear a bear it was far hey
that's inappropriate
you're safe Bears can't climb trees of
course they can
[Music]
oh [__]
it kind of seems like the thing that
stays with a man forever
apex predator
high on cocaine
thought of it's mine
oh man you [__] what the [__] is wrong
with that man
[Music]
we have such good luck in nature
thank you